there's a bill in South Carolina that's
been filed by state representative bill
Chumley and it would prevent people who
buy computers in South Carolina from
accessing pornography on the Internet
now how would this be done well South
Carolina would mandate that sellers of
computers have to install digital
blocking capabilities on computers as
well as other electronic devices that
are internet connected to prevent the
viewing of so-called obscene content now
this story has nothing to do with your
personal opinion about pornography if
we're talking about legal porn with of
aged actors this is the government in
this case a state government picking and
choosing based on their present personal
morals it is arbitrary it is capricious
it is censorship period now when you
look at the bill you could say well
there's a way around it because both
buyers and sellers can get around these
blocking software's for a fee
the bill would find manufacturers if
they sell a device without the system
altogether but they can opt out by
paying 20 bucks for each device that
they sell but also buyers have the
opportunity to verify their age and pay
20 bucks to remove the filter so number
one we have a state mandated
pre-installed ransomware
being installed on computers which is
insane and number two if you're arguing
that the porn is so damaging to society
that it has to be banned how do you
simultaneously justify getting around
the ban legally for 20 bucks I mean just
none of this makes any sense and I keep
hearing that conservatives are the small
government right this is just their
latest attempt to get in between people
and their bedrooms but porn filters are
notoriously fruitless we saw this with
Utah when they had the resolution ban
and that didn't take any traction and it
was just perpetrated by the Mormon
Church this it doesn't really matter how
you attempt to do it obviously people
can get around it you can also buy a
computer online from a company that's
not in your state if you go I mean I'm
not exactly sure where all Dell
computers are made
but Dell I believe is at least based in
Texas if you buy a Dell on the internet
and it's sent to you my understanding
based on how I read the bill is that you
wouldn't be affected at all if anything
this stands to just hurt the businesses
of South Carolina and Pat you're making
a good point which is they claim small
government right they have these memes
they repeat like only rules laws and
regulations that are absolutely
necessary how do you argue that this is
absolutely necessary but then when you
do any more than a superficial analysis
if you're a small computer store in
South Carolina if they even still exist
anymore who even knows at this point and
you're hearing about this there's a
really big risk that people are going to
instead of shopping local just go online
and skip a computer that comes with
pre-installed ransomware I feel like
they're not even thinking of how it will
affect their local businesses in this
particular case I'd be furious if I was
a South Carolina electronic store yeah
it's all about optics and you know it's
a case of censorship and infringing on
people on civil liberties and the exact
same thing they criticize liberals for
doing and then of course big picture
with all the problems in the world
actually you don't even really need to
look around the world with all the
problems in South Carolina disastrous
education terrible job situation
terrible health care situation they're
choosing to focus on the porn ban so
that's where I come full circle Rachel
and say oh if they're choosing to focus
on this then it's probably because you
can raise a lot of money from someone I
would guess religious conservatives by
playing I am the moral crusader is there
maybe something to that I think so but I
feel like with the history on how these
type of porn pants have done it ends up
is coming across as more of a statement
than anything that will actually have a
tangible change absolutely and
completely authoritarian and this is
this is no different if you want to make
the case that if you're talking about
underage child pornography or something
like that something that is actually
illegal you're talking about a very
different situation and regardless of
your personal feelings about pornography
if this is content that is legal you
were talking about the government
picking and choosing to censor certain
types of speech and I know that
sometimes we hear Oh political donations
or speech corporation
they're people and there's pretty strong
arguments to be made against that
there's really no strong argument to be
made that legally produced porn with of
aged actors that limiting that is not an
infringement on speech it's absolutely a
form of speech you might not like the
speech but it is speech and there are
reasonable restrictions on free speech
that we have you can't make threats
against someone for example and everyone
always goes to the example that you
can't yell fire in a crowded theater
right this is just not one of those
reasonable examples not at all and it's
just absolutely laughable that a state
that is in such trouble I mean really
big trouble because of all the decisions
that Republicans like nikki Haley for
example have made over the last two
knows how many years have really hurt
that state and they're focusing on porn
bands that you can pay 20 bucks to
uninstall that ransomware that comes
preinstalled it is just laughable thanks
for watching this video before you watch
the next one remember we're raising
money to expand the David Pakman show
big league as well as expand progressive
activism go to david pakman.com slash
donate donations of any size are much
appreciated